[Música]
el gobierno de Perú oficializó la
declaración del estado de emergencia
para todo el país y por ahora no aplica
el toque de queda a medida que regirá
por 30 días obedece a las protestas y
bloqueos que se desataron tras la
destitución de Pedro castillo y que ya
dejan ocho personas muertas
Francia venció a Marruecos por dos goles
a cero y llega a la final de la Copa del
Mundo para enfrentarse a Argentina los
dos bicampeones mundiales buscarán
alcanzar su tercer título este domingo
bajo el liderazgo de Lionel Messi y
kilian mbappé tenemos reacciones de los
jugadores
América Latina es la región más
peligrosa para ejercer periodismo según
el más reciente reporte de reporteros
Sin fronteras la región registra casi la
mitad de los asesinatos contra
periodistas México encabeza la lista
seguido de Haití y Brasil
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 lo saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú el gobierno
emitió el decreto con el que se
oficializa el estado de emergencia que
regirá en todo el país durante 30 días
pero en el documento no se hace mención
a un toque de queda como lo había
previsto el ministro de defensa por otro
lado la justicia peruana aplazó para
mañana a la audiencia programada para
definir la prisión preventiva contra el
ex mandatario por lo que Pedro Castillo
debe permanecer detenido hasta que se
aclare su situación previamente nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
nos contaba las reacciones de los
peruanos a la declaración del estado de
emergencia
Andrés Buenas tardes existen posiciones
encontradas por un lado se le critica a
la presidenta Dina boluarte de demorarse
en establecer el principio de autoridad
y dejar que las protestas se incrementen
en todo el Perú mientras que otros
señalan que establecer el estado de
emergencia nacional por 30 días implica
suspender derechos constitucionales como
la inviolabilidad de domicilio la
libertad de tránsito la libertad de
reunión y la la seguridad personal y eso
también significa alterar la Navidad
para más de 33 millones de peruanos por
culpa de miles de manifestantes por otro
lado se espera que esta noche la
presidenta Dina boluarte declare la
instalación de un toque de queda en el
país para controlar los desmanes
Mientras tanto la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas ha mostrado su
preocupación por la situación que vive
Perú en este momento y se ha hecho un
llamado y recomendación a conservar el
estado de derecho y dejar las vías para
que los peruanos puedan expresar su voz
y también manifestarse Pero siempre y
cuando esto sea de manera pacífica vamos
con noticias del fútbol y la victoria de
Francia sobre Marruecos en la semifinal
de la copa del mundo el equipo de didier
de champs aprovechó su primera llegada
en el minuto 5 para marcar el primer gol
convertido porteo Hernández en el minuto
78 Randall colomoani convirtió el
segundo y sentenció el partido tanto
Francia como Argentina buscarán sumar
una tercera estrella a su camiseta el
domingo en la gran final de Qatar 2022
los jugadores de la selección de Francia
reflexionaron sobre la posibilidad de
convertirse en el primer equipo de más
de 60 años en ganar Dos copas del mundo
seguidas y sobre el rival que les espera
el domingo Así la verdad que hemos
trabajado mucho
esta semana para para poder llegar a la
final y espero esperamos después de
hacer muy feliz a todos los franceses
como he dicho sabemos que Argentina
tiene un muy buen equipo y va a ser Va a
ser un partido muy difícil pero nosotros
ahora tenemos que recuperar bien y
preparar bien este partido
vimos todos los partidos del torneo
Vimos a Argentina son un poco como
nosotros un colectivo fuerte con un
jugador que sobresale
sabemos que el lío Es lo mejor que hay
en el mundo Entonces tenemos que
preparar bien este partido y ver cómo
podemos hacerles daño pero también
defendernos y estar listos a un 100%
para el domingo
seguimos hablando de Qatar La estricta
regulación sobre el alcohol genera
espacios más seguros para las mujeres de
lo que es habitual en los entornos
deportivos occidentales así lo han
declarado aficionados al fútbol
extranjeros que acostumbradas a las
celebraciones alrededor del alcohol
dicen sufrir menos de acoso sexual
informe de Rosa Pérez Mateo
menos alcohol menos acoso sexual es lo
que aseguran aficionadas al fútbol a
raíz de su experiencia en el mundial de
Qatar
Yo no bebo pero sí me siento más segura
porque cuando hay alcohol la gente está
más alterada Así que nos sentimos más
seguras
no importa si los partidos terminan
tarde por la noche o si vuelves a tu
hotel muy tarde te sientes seguro en
todas partes
las restricciones al consumo de alcohol
en la monarquía del Golfo han causado
que mujeres occidentales aficionadas al
deporte acostumbradas a sufrir acoso en
celebraciones regadas de alcohol lleguen
a alabar el ambiente en Qatar así lo
declaró en un artículo para el periódico
británico de Times la inglesa El Limón
directora de hard game to también su
partido una campaña para mejorar las
experiencias de las mujeres en los
ámbitos deportivos no lo son y muchas
otras aficionadas inglesas aseguran que
este mundial podría servir de modelo
para los juegos en casa venir aquí ha
sido un verdadero shock dijo moloson no
ha habido silbidos acoso o sexismo de
ningún tipo unas declaraciones que se
viralizaron y levantaron polémica hasta
el punto que el activista aclaró su
comentario las redes sociales afirman
que dije que era seguro para todas las
mujeres nunca lo dije nunca ignoraría
las leyes anti lgbt y las leyes de
tutela de las mujeres
Qatar es objeto de críticas
internacionales por su legislación
opresiva con las mujeres y las personas
lgbtq más sin embargo el bienestar
expresado por mujeres extranjeras en el
mundial es revelador de una problemática
normalizada en occidente
cambiamos de tema el más reciente
informe de reporteros Sin fronteras
indica que América Latina es la región
más peligrosa del mundo para ejercer el
periodismo la región registra casi la
mitad de los 57 asesinatos contra
periodistas que se reportaron en lo que
va de 2022 México encabeza la lista de
países más afectados con 11 periodistas
asesinados le sigue Haití con 6 y Brasil
con tres en France 24 Arthur Romeo
director de reporteros Sin fronteras en
América Latina reiteró que el fenómeno
no es nuevo el tema es que aunque las
cifras sean impresionantes ese año el
problema de la violencia en contra de
los periodistas en América Latina es un
tema histórico O sea no no es reciente
no no está asociado con particularidades
específicas del año de 2022 pero es un
problema que ya viene de desde hace
décadas vemos por ejemplo el caso de
México que es el cuarto año consecutivo
en que es el país del mundo más
mortífero para los trabajadores de
medios
para los periodistas y comunicadores en
general También tenemos el caso de Haití
que ahí tenemos una sorpresa no porque
Haití en los años anteriores no había
casos de asesinatos de periodistas o
algunos casos puntuales pero con todos
los hechos de la crisis política de
seguridad pública que vive el país los
periodistas han sido blancos
sistemáticos de ataques y fueron
asesinados en varios en varios casos o
sea el periodismo ejerce un control
social sobre el poder y el hecho de que
ejerces contra ese control social hace
con que son blancos se vuelven se se
vuelven en blancos de ataques por
personas que ocupan esos espacios de
poderes que sean estatales o no no como
de crimen del crimen organizado de
carteles de pandillas a de grupos
delincuentes de manera general de grupos
paramilitares que van a intentar
silenciar Esas voces las autoridades
chinas advirtieron de una rápida
propagación del en la capital Beijing
después de que el país abandonara
abruptamente su política de tolerancia
cero los cambios provocaron una Euforia
que rápidamente se convirtió en temor de
que el país pueda pagar un alto precio
por la decisión lea Uriel nos cuenta más
Beijing y sus 22 millones de habitantes
frente a una ola inédita de contagios
estas colas ante los hospitales las
farmacias y las clínicas muestran como
el covid está afectando a la capital
china a pesar del aumento de infecciones
algunos están menos preocupados por el
virus en sí
mucha gente de mi entorno se ha
contagiado creo que no pasa nada es como
estar resfriado unos días y no durará
mucho creo que todo el mundo se
contagiará no hay por qué ponerse
nervioso solo es cuestión de tiempo que
te contagies
Después de tres años de restricciones
drásticas se decretó el fin de las
campañas de detección masiva con pruebas
pcr en las ciudades chinas lo que
dificultara la detección de contagios
asintomáticos el Ministerio de sanidad
admitió que por eso el alcance de la
epidemia es ahora imposible de
determinar pero las autoridades
anunciaron que seguirían vigilando las
instituciones sanitarias
se espera que a través de la
monitorización podamos comprender la
escala la intensidad el alcance de la
pandemia y la mutación del virus de una
manera relativamente oportuna
en un Cumple tu revés de su estrategia
anterior el gobierno chino parece ahora
decidido a seguir reabriendo el país los
viajes en grupo desde y Asia Beijing se
reanudaron desde el martes pero esta ola
podría ser dura para el sistema
hospitalario tal como para las personas
mayores entre las que hay bajas tasas de
vacunación
hasta que es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]